The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
You all should have these
handouts ready to go now.
Let's review where we were last
week.
If everyone can settle down a
little bit, you can discuss
about who wants to be the top
chemistry major later on,
after class is over.
All right.
Octahedral case.
Here is our octahedral
molecule.
And, again, crystal field
theory is just an explanation
for the things that are observed
experimentally.
It is a fairly simple theory.
And, if you go on to study
chemistry, and you will take
more inorganic chemistry later
on, you will learn about more
complicated theories.
But this is really simple.
This simple theory just thinks
about each ligand,
each small molecule,
like NH three group,
bound to a metal.
The metal is in the center
position.
That each ligand considers as a
negative point charge.
And so then the theory looks at
whether that ligand,
as a negative point charge,
is pointing toward one of the
d-orbitals.
You need to know about the
shapes of the d-orbitals.
And you need to know about the
shapes of the coordination
complexes.
And then you need to just ask
yourself, is that ligand
pointing directly toward a
d-orbital.
If it is, then it will be
destabilized.
If it is not,
then those orbitals will be
stabilized.
And so you are talking about
the stabilization relative to an
imaginary spherical and crystal
field, where ligands are just
sort of everywhere all around
the center metal.
You consider that as sort of
your standard case where all of
the d-orbitals have the same
energy.
But then when you consider
those ligands as negative point
charges in particular locations,
some d-orbitals then get
destabilized,
and other ones get stabilized,
in terms of energy.
In the octahedral case then,
and here is our little cartoon
for the octahedral case where
there are ligands along the
z-axis, ligands along the
x-axis, and ligands along the
y-axis.
And so if you look at d x
squared minus y squared,
you see that the
ligands will be pointing
directly toward these
d-orbitals, because ligands are
coming along y and along x.
And so there will be a lot of
destabilization.
For d z squared,
you have ligands pointing
directly toward those orbitals
as well along the z-axis.
These have large repulsions due
to the negative point charges.
Those negative point charges
are heading right toward those
d-orbitals.
And these two are degenerate
with respect to each other.
They have the same energy,
the same amount of
destabilization.
And these are destabilized
compared to this other set of
d-orbitals.
And in this set of d-orbitals,
none of the orbitals are
on-axis.
They are 45 degrees off-axis.
The negative point charges are
on-axis.
There is not as much
destabilization.
The ligands are not pointing
directly toward any of these
d-orbitals.
You have smaller repulsion.
All of these three of the same
energy, they are degenerate.
And they are all stabilized
compared to this set.
That is what we talked about
last week.
And we also talked about how
you can draw an octahedral
crystal field splitting diagram.
And here is the average energy
of the d-orbitals with this sort
of spherical crystal field where
ligands are everywhere.
And so when ligands are
everywhere, all of the
d-orbitals have the same energy.
But then when you put the
ligands in their locations,
in the octahedral geometry
framework, then these two sets
of orbitals, d x squared minus y
squared and d z
squared,
are up in energy,
they are destabilized.
And these three go down in
energy.
And the overall energy of the
system is maintained.
Here is the crystal field
splitting energy for the
octahedral case,
O for octahedral.
And so it is split.
Two orbitals go up in energy,
so they go up by three-fifths,
three go down,
so they go down by two-fifths
to maintain the overall energy
of this system.
That is what we talked about
last time, and I just wanted to
review it, because we are going
to go on and talk about other
types of geometry.
And, of course,
remember that Exam 3 is on
Wednesday.
Extra problems are posted.
I will mention that I actually
posted the original exam last
year, and the exam that people
took was slightly easier than
the one I posted.
I did that actually by mistake.
But it turns out that if you do
the exam that is posted it is a
better indicator of how well you
will do on this next exam.
The third exam last year was a
bit too easy,
i.e., too easy meaning the sort
of outstanding category was like
98% and above.
And if you got a 97% then that
was no longer outstanding,
so whether you got three
significant figures wrong or two
made some difference in your
grade.
That clustering I don't like.
I like to have the average such
that people's performance on the
exam really indicates more how
well they know the material.
The exam that is posted is
actually the better review.
Even though that was an
accident, I will pretend I did
it on purpose because it is a
better thing.
So, extra problems on.
Today, we are going to finish
up crystal field theory and then
talk about the relevance of
crystal field theory.
And the relevance comes in to
explaining the colors of these
transition compounds.
Compounds with metals have some
really spectacular colors.
And you can explain and
rationalize some of these colors
by this really very simple
theory, so that is fun.
And you can also explain some
of the properties and magnetism
of these compounds by this
fairly simple theory.
Okay.
Let's look at the tetrahedral
case now.
Here, we have our tetrahedral
molecule.
I will try to kind of hold it
up as it is displayed on the
board.
In this case,
we have two ligands up,
one coming towards you,
one going back.
And then we have two ligands in
the plane of the screen.
And, in this case,
the convention is to draw the
z-axis coming down here,
and the y-axis is kind of
coming in from the side,
and the x-axis is coming out
toward you here.
That is what this picture
indicates.
The crystal field splitting
energy tends to be smaller than
the octahedral crystal field
energy because none of the
ligand point charges are really
pointing toward any of the
d-orbitals.
Let's just take a look at all
the d-orbitals and consider,
then, which ones are going to
have more repulsion than other
ones.
If we go through and take a
look at it, and I have tried to
indicate, here are our
tetrahedral cases and here are
five d-orbitals.
And these little lines,
the negative charge and the
arrow, is sort of a rough
approximation of how those
ligand point charges are going
to be coming in and pointing
toward the d-orbitals if they
are coming in with this
tetrahedral geometry as drawn.
And so you can see for the d x
squared minus y squared,
none of those ligands
are pointing right any of the
d-orbitals, and they are
definitely not for the d z
squared either.
A little bit more here but,
again, not exactly pointing
toward them.
Although, this picture looks
like it is a little bit.
Again, it is closer here,
but not exact.
The result of this is that
there is more destabilization
down here than there is up here.
It turns out that this is then
opposite of the octahedral case
that we just talked about.
And octahedral,
these are the ones that are
most destabilized.
In tetrahedral,
these are stabilized compared
to the others.
It is flipped exactly around.
Again, there would be more
repulsion between the ligands as
negative point charges and the
orbitals that are 45 degree
off-axis.
Because here,
the ligands are off axis and
also the orbitals are off axis.
They are not directly pointing
at each other but it is
definitely worse down here.
These guys are really far away
from those ligand point charges.
These two will have the same
energy with respect to each
other.
They will also be degenerate,
as they were before.
And these three have the same
energy with respect to each
other.
They are also degenerate.
Then we can draw what the
diagram will look like for the
tetrahedral case.
Again, here was the octahedral
case.
Now, this is the tetrahedral
And so we have the splitting
energy, which is the energy that
splits the orbitals based on
these negative point charges
compared to this theoretical
spherical crystal field.
And we also have a tetrahedral
crystal field splitting energy.
That is drawn here.
Now, the first thing,
which I emphasize that I will
point out again,
is that these guys are flipped
around.
Instead of being destabilized
as they are in the octahedral
crystal field,
the d x squared minus y squared
and d z squared
are now stabilized
compared to the other orbital
set.
They have switched positions.
These, instead of being
stabilized, are more
destabilized.
It is a direct switch.
There is also a little change
in nomenclature here.
You can still refer to this
orbital set with the term E.
But instead of e g we
have E.
And I will just point out that
the book calls this E two
and sometimes it calls
it E.
It should just be E.
This is kind of a small point,
but I don't want people to get
confused by that.
And instead of t two g,
we have t two up here.
Basically, the g term is gone
in this case.
And you will learn a lot more
about that if you go on and take
more inorganic chemistry.
These are flipped.
What else is true?
Well, the other thing that is
true is that this splitting
energy is much smaller in the
tetrahedral case than it is in
the octahedral case.
Here there is a much bigger
distance between the orbitals.
Here it is a much smaller
distance.
And that is because in the
octahedral case,
there are ligands pointing
directly at the d-orbitals.
In this framework for
octahedral, there are ligands
right along z,
along x, and along y.
And so they are along all of
the orbitals,
pointing directly toward the
orbitals.
In the tetrahedral case,
they are not really pointing
directly toward.
They are closer to some than to
others, but it is not as direct.
A result of that is that this
is just not split that much.
There is not such a huge
difference between the energy
levels of the d-orbitals in this
case.
What does this mean?
Well, it means that a lot of
tetrahedral complexes,
because the splitting energy is
small, are called high spin.
And we talked about this last
Monday, that in high spin you
have the maximum number of
unpaired electrons.
And because of the purpose of
this you can just assume that if
you have a tetrahedral complex,
is will be high spin.
That will come into play when
you figure out how to put your
electrons into this diagram,
whether you put them in singly
to the fullest extent possible
without pairing,
or if you start to pair.
In this case,
you can put them in singly to
the fullest extent possible.
Okay.
As I mentioned before,
the overall energy of this
system is maintained.
In this case,
you have two orbitals that go
up in energy.
They go up by three-fifths.
Three that come down,
so they come down by
two-fifths.
In this case,
you have three going up,
so they will go up by
two-fifths.
And you have two going down in
energy, so they will go down by
three-fifths to maintain the
overall energy of the system.
That's the tetrahedral case.
Now let's consider square
planar.
Here, we have our square planar
molecule, and we have ligands
along the y-axis,
and ligands along the x-axis
pointing out towards you;
one, and one going back behind.
And z, then,
is coming up and down in this
plane.
With these ligands along y and
along x, which orbitals do you
predict would be destabilized
the most?
I heard d xy.
That is one.
What else?
d x squared minus y squared,
right.
Those two.
The ones that don't have the
z-component in them.
There is really not much
destabilization along z.
There are no ligands along z.
Orbitals that have amplitude
along z are not as affected.
The ones that will be most
affected are the orbitals that
have component in the x and the
y direction, where the ligands
are.
Now we can consider the
d-orbitals and talk a little bit
more about this.
If we look at these two sets of
orbitals now,
here, as you correctly
predicted, there will be lots of
repulsion.
The ligands are pointing
directly at these d-orbitals.
The ligands are on-axis.
The orbitals are on-axis.
It is a direct hit.
There is a lot of
destabilization.
And this one now is going to be
destabilized compared to all
other ones.
It is going to be by itself,
the most destabilized orbital.
d z squared doesn't
really have much destabilization
at all.
In fact, it will be stabilized.
There are no ligands along z,
there is no real repulsion of
the ligands to d z squared,
so it is going to be
a lot less than for this guy and
also less than d xy.
We can draw this now,
put in two of the orbitals.
This one is going to be way up.
It is going to be by far the
most destabilized.
It is going to even go up from
where it was in the octahedral
case.
Whereas, d z squared,
which was up here,
degenerate with d x squared
minus y squared
in the octahedral case,
is now going to drop way down.
These are not equivalent at all
anymore.
And so this makes sense.
The difference between the
octahedral geometry is that
there are ligands along z.
Now the ligands along z are
gone in the square planar case,
so there is a big difference
between these two orbitals sets
in terms of energy.
Now, let's look at these three.
This one, as people correctly
predicted, is going to have a
lot more repulsion than either
of these, because the orbitals
have maximum amplitude along x
and y.
They are actually 45 degrees
off x and y, but still,
we don't have anything in the
z-component here.
This will be destabilized
compared to these two.
And these two are stabilized
compared to the d-orbitals
d xy, d x squared minus y
squared.
Now we can go and take a look
at where these would be
positioned approximately.
If we look at this one,
it is not nearly as
destabilized as this one.
Still, it is a bit destabilized
and above this.
This one is lower in energy.
And if you consider the
difference here,
again, d x squared minus y
squared,
the ligands are pointing
directly at the orbitals.
It is on-axis.
Here, it is 45 degrees
off-axis, so it is not as
destabilized,
but still is up above where it
was in the octahedral case.
And then, finally,
these two guys are going to be
stabilized compared to this
theoretical spherical crystal
field.
They are going to be somewhere
down here.
The big points here then are
that, compared to the octahedral
case, when you get rid of the
ligands along z,
this guys shoots up,
this one comes down,
it is stabilized.
The other d-orbital that has
maximum components along x and
y, which is where those ligands
are, goes up a little.
These three are all sort of
stabilized, these two are
destabilized,
but this one is destabilized
quite a bit more.
These also will have,
you can draw sort of splitting
energies here,
but that is just too
complicated.
We are only going to do this
with the octahedral and
tetrahedral case,
because there are many more
layers here.
And these are little bit
different.
All you need to know is sort of
this relative ratio.
This is the most destabilized.
This is next.
These guys are stabilized.
That is all you need to know.
We are not going to draw
splitting energies going up by
one-fifth and things like that
for this case,
but you will hear about this
more if you go on in chemistry.
What I expect you to know is to
be able to rationalize.
If you know something about the
shape of a molecule,
suppose you had a linear
molecule along the z-axis,
a good test question might be
which orbitals would be the most
destabilized,
if you are linear,
along z, for example.
You should be able to think
about the shapes of the
d-orbitals, think about the
shapes of the molecules,
and predict the orbitals with
the most stabilization and the
most destabilization and to be
able to explain your rationale
for predicting these splitting
diagrams.
Now, we are going to talk about
how these diagrams and thinking
about the splitting of the
d-orbitals can explain the
beautiful colors of these
coordination complexes.
Let's go back to the octahedral
case for a minute and talk about
two different octahedral
complexes.
We have iron plus three
in two different
complexes.
We have a high spin state,
with iron and six water
ligands, and a low spin molecule
coordination compound,
with iron and six cyanide
ligands.
The first thing you are going
to do, if you are going to be
talking about the splitting,
is to figure out how many
electrons you are talking about,
or come up with the d-electron
count.
Let's do that.
If we have iron with six water
ligands.
The overall charge on that is
three plus.
What is going to be our,
and this is on the board,
too, but what will be the
oxidation number of iron?
Plus three.
This is zero.
And so it all has to equal plus
three.
Then the d-count is going to be
equal to --
And I will put up a Periodic
Table.
The d-count will be equal to
what?
Five, right.
We look up the group number,
which is 8, minus 3 is going to
be 5.
And our other iron complex will
be the same.
This one has a charge of minus
three.
Cyanide is  what?
Minus one.
Iron would also have to be plus
three to get the correct overall
charge.
Our d-count over here as well
is going to be d five.
We have the same number of
electrons that we need to put
into two different diagrams.
We have one.
This is our high spin case.
And so we can draw the crystal
field splitting diagram for the
high spin --
-- and put in our orbitals.
d x squared minus y squared,
d z squared.
We have our octahedral crystal
field splitting energy.
We are going up by three-fifths
and down by two-fifths for these
compared to this theoretical
crystal field.
And then we have our low spin
case.
In our low spin case,
we have a larger splitting
energy.
Again, some are going to go up
by three-fifths and three will
go down by two-fifths.
Now, we need to put in our five
electrons.
How am I going to put them in
here?
Will I fill up all of the
different energy levels with one
before I pair,
or will I start to pair in the
lower, first?
We are going to put them in
everywhere first.
We will put all five electrons.
We will put one in each of the
orbitals.
I am going to place them singly
in.
That is because in this case,
the splitting energy is small.
And, since it is small,
it is less than the pairing
energy.
The pairing energy is the
energy required to pair up these
electrons.
There is a certain amount of
repulsion.
All of the electrons would love
to be alone in their orbital.
They would prefer not for you
to put another electron in.
There is a certain amount of
energy required to do this.
If the energy level between the
d-orbitals is small,
then you put them all in singly
and don't pair until you
absolutely have to.
This is referred to as the high
spin case, where you have the
maximum number of unpaired
electrons.
In this case,
we have a large energy.
That energy,
then, is greater than the
energy required to pair --
-- The PE or the pairing
energy.
Now we are going to put them
all into the bottom until we
have to go to the top.
We will first start out putting
them in singly,
one, two, three,
and then we will start pairing,
four, five.
Now we fill up this bottom set.
I should put in the t two g
and the e g
labels.
We will put them in this bottom
set in t two g until
we have to go up to e g.
Because this is a big energy
difference.
And you don't want to do that
until you have to.
All right.
Now we can look at the
d-electron count,
so where the electrons are.
Here it is t two g three.
There are three in the bottom.
And in e g there are
two.
And over here,
in t two g, we have five.
There are none in e.
Those are our d-electron
counts.
And then, we can calculate the
crystal field stabilization
energy, which shouldn't be
confused with the splitting
energy.
This considers how much
stabilization you have as a
result of the fact that the
d-orbitals are split in energy.
In this case,
you want to count up how many
are in the lower energy levels.
There are three down here.
Three times minus two-fifths
the octahedral crystal field
splitting energy.
And you have two above,
so two are up in energy by
three-fifths.
And so what does that equal?
Zero.
And over here then you have
five that are down in energy.
You would have minus
ten-fifths, the octahedral
crystal field splitting energy.
And sometimes in some books it
also includes,
there is some energy associated
with pairing,
so occasionally you will see
this written as two PE,
indicating that there are two
sets with paired electrons.
There is some energy associated
with that.
It is not as fantastic a
situation as it look like.
That there is lots of
stabilization where the other
has a zero stabilization,
zero destabilization,
it is just about the same,
but there is some energy
associated with this so
sometimes you will see that.
And you only need to indicate
that if it is asked for.
And I think your book doesn't
ask for it, but just so you are
aware.
All right.
That is kind of a review.
We talked about these things
last Monday, but I just wanted
to go through it again because
now you need to see how this
relates to colors.
We have to introduce this idea
that the relative ability of
certain common ligands to split
the d-orbital level is what is
meant by this spectrochemical
series.
Which ligands there are,
in one case,
water and cyanide,
causes a difference.
And a strong field ligand,
and we talked about this a bit
last Monday as well,
produces large energy
separation.
Over here we have a large
energy, so this would be a
strong field over here.
It is strong.
It splits those d-orbitals a
lot.
And a weak field ligand
produces a small separation.
It is pretty weak.
It cannot really split those
d-orbitals very much.
It is weak.
This would be a weak field
case, over here.
There is not much splitting
between the d-orbitals.
Here are some various ligands
and how they fall into this
series.
And you need to know this for
the test, only these sets of
ligands.
There are three in the sort of
weak field category.
Three in the intermediate
category.
Three in the strong field
When it is a weak field ligand,
you are going to have the small
splitting, as shown here.
Therefore, you will have a high
spin system where you have the
maximum number of unpaired
electrons.
If you have a strong field,
you have a large splitting.
And then you are going to have
a low spin system,
where you have the minimum
number of unpaired electrons.
In the example that we just
had, this is high spin,
so it is actually kind of an
intermediate,
but it was determined to be
high spin experimentally.
The intermediate ones are a
little harder to predict.
These will be strong field.
These will be weak field.
These are harder to predict.
Cyanide, according to this
list, is the strongest field
ligand.
That makes sense that that was,
then, a low spin system.
Colors are going to depend on
what photons are absorbed and
the energy level it takes to get
to that excited high energy
state.
Here, it is a very small
difference.
Here it is a big difference.
You would need to absorb
differently and then also
transmit differently to excite
those electrons.
That is going to give rise to
the different colors.
Let's just take a look at this.
Now, we are reviewing back to
the first half of the semester,
where you saw this.
We have the energy of the
absorbed light is equal to
Planck's constant times the
frequency.
And so we are back here again.
We are talking about splitting
energies between the d-orbitals,
the amount of energy to excite
an electron from one set of
orbitals to the higher set of
orbitals.
We are back here.
But now we are going to have a
little bit of difference in that
we are going to add another
equal sign and say that the
energy then is going to be,
in this case with a transition
metal complexes,
octahedral coordination
complexes, it is equal to this
octahedral crystal field
splitting energy.
Again, we are going to be
talking about exciting electrons
here up to here.
And so that depends,
then, on what the energy
difference is between these sets
of orbitals.
We have seen this before,
and now we are just adding this
new term on the other end,
the octahedral crystal field
splitting energy.
All right.
This we also saw in the first
half of the course.
If you have a high frequency of
light absorbed,
the wavelength of the absorbed
light is going to be short.
And that is that equation.
I think these two equations
were equations you needed to
have memorized.
They were not on the equation
sheet.
That indicates that they are of
really fundamental importance.
And then, the color of the
transmitted light is
complementary to the color of
the absorbed light.
Here we need to think beyond
the first half of the semester
back to, probably,
kindergarten.
When did you first learn about
complementary colors?
Second grade?
I actually was talked into
putting something like this on
the exam, so that you wouldn't
have to have that material
memorized.
Anyway, here are your
complementary colors.
If you know something about the
color of the transition complex,
you can go back and calculate
and estimate.
If you are given actual
numbers, you can calculate what
the splitting energy difference
was, or you can approximate
whether it is going to be small
or large depending on the colors
that the complexes have.
Let's take a look at some
examples, here,
of two different coordination
complexes, both octahedral.
First, we have to figure out
the oxidation number.
Again, this goes back to the
last unit on
oxidation-reduction,
useful for the exam on
Wednesday.
The number here,
you are going to have plus
three for both of these guys.
This is zero and that is zero.
The overall charge is plus
three, so chromium has to be
plus three in both cases.
Then, when we do the d-electron
count, we have to find chromium
on our Periodic Table.
Look up what group it is in to
calculate the d-count.
We have that here.
And we have a d three
case.
What does CN stand for?
Coordination number.
And so what is the coordination
number in this case?
Six, right.
There are six things here,
six things coordinated.
And that is not to be confused
with a steric number,
which we talked about last
Wednesday.
The type of ligand here,
water, was what?
What type of ligand,
in terms of weak to strong
field?
It was intermediate.
And over here?
It is stronger.
These guys are actually not
that far apart from each other.
Water was sort of intermediate.
It is at least weaker than NH
three.
NH three was in the
strong category,
so it is at least stronger than
water.
They are not that far apart
from each other,
but this one should be a
stronger field ligand than this
one.
If we consider a weaker field
system and a stronger field
system, is this going to make
any difference to how we put in
electrons this time?
No, it won't,
because we only have three.
We would put them in the bottom
regardless.
The issue is when you get to
the fourth one.
When you have a fourth electron
you have to decide if you are
going to put it up here or if
you are going to pair,
but there are only three,
so the diagrams look the same.
Even though the diagrams look
the same, these compounds are
going to have different
properties because they have
different splitting energies.
And so the amount of energy
required to bump an electron up
here is going to be different
than up here.
And so you will have different
colors as a result.
Let's take a look at that.
Again, this is intermediate,
so this is smaller.
This is stronger,
it is large,
it doesn't affect how the
electrons go in,
but it does affect the property
of the compound.
Let's go through this and see
what this means.
Water, then,
is weaker.
It means the splitting energy
is smaller.
If the splitting energy is
smaller, that means you have a
lower energy,
a smaller energy between them
and a lower frequency that will
be absorbed.
In this case,
this is a strong field ligand,
so you will have a larger
energy and a higher frequency
that is absorbed.
Over here, if we have the lower
frequency absorbed,
we have a longer wavelength
absorbed.
For the stronger field case,
we have somewhat of a higher
frequency absorbed,
so we will have somewhat of a
shorter wavelength absorbed.
And then, the color of the
transmitted light is
complimentary to the color of
the absorbed light.
Here you are going to have a
transmitted light with a shorter
wavelength.
You had a longer wavelength
absorbed, so you will have a
shorter wavelength transmitted.
And this compound is,
in fact, violet.
Over here you are going to have
the shorter wavelength absorbed,
so the transmitted light will
be complimentary to that and we
will have a longer wavelength.
And this compound is,
in fact, yellow.
If we look again at the colors
and their wavelengths --
This complex with the strong
field ligand is yellow and the
one with an intermediate field
ligand is violet,
somewhere down in here.
Even though water and NH three
are close to each other,
the one that is stronger
definitely has quite a distinct
color from the one that is a bit
weaker.
And, unless you are given
numbers, you cannot predict
exactly which color.
You can just rationalize the
relationship.
If you were told this is yellow
and this is violet,
tell me why,
you would say,
this is a stronger field ligand
than this one.
That is the kind of thing you
can do.
But if you are given numbers,
and on problems and on the
final you may be given numbers,
you can actually come up and
calculate back and forth from
the splitting energy to the
color that you predict,
from a color back to the
splitting energy.
What things would be colorless?
Which kind of coordination
complexes would be colorless,
and why would it be colorless?
This is where things written in
your handout can be read back to
me.
[LAUGHTER] Unless you know,
but it is good to think about
it a little bit.
Okay.
If you filled up all your
d-orbitals and there is no room
for things to move around,
when it is not possible to have
a d-to-d transition,
you filled up everything,
so you are not going to be able
to do this transition from one
set of d-orbitals to another
one, then you have colorless.
Here are some examples of
things that will be colorless,
and let's just prove that that
would be true,
that those are,
in fact, filled.
We have zinc and cadmium.
If we look, zinc and cadmium
are in Group 12.
They both have oxidation
numbers of plus two,
so 12 minus 2 is 10.
You have a d ten
system.
This one is also going to be a
d ten system.
You are going to have all ten
electrons already in,
and so you are not going to
have these transitions.
And so these,
in fact, are colorless.
Zinc is a really important
metal in biology.
And it plays structural roles.
It can play catalytic roles.
It is a very important metal.
And often, when biochemists are
trying to figure out how a
protein works,
they won't realize it is a zinc
containing enzyme,
because the protein won't have
any color.
In contrast,
there are proteins and
cofactors in metals that have a
lot of color.
And then, actually,
as you are purifying the
enzyme, it will have this bright
orange or red color.
And you realize it has some
metal cofactor in it,
right from the very beginning.
Just to go through then and
sort of summarize this whole
procedure, if you are on this
end with the ligands in the weak
field ligands,
then you are going to have a
small splitting.
Weak things cannot split much.
They do not have enough
strength to really split those
d-orbitals apart.
You will have a high spin
system in this case,
a maximum number of unpaired
electrons.
In terms of the complexes,
then they will absorb low
energy photons,
low frequency,
long wavelength,
and then they will transmit
high frequency or short
wavelength.
They are going to be in this
violet blue-green end of the
spectra.
And let me just put this one
up.
Actually, I will put all these
guys up.
They will be on this end of the
spectra.
Again, it is all based on these
two equations.
If you have a small splitting,
small energy,
you are going to have a low
frequency.
And then you will have a long
wavelength for absorbed.
And the complimentary for the
transmitted.
If you are a strong field,
you will have a large splitting
energy.
It will be low spin,
minimum number of unpaired
electrons, and you will have a
situation like this.
Here you fill them up to
maximum extent.
Here they are low spin,
maximum paired,
so then you will have the
complimentary.
You have short wavelength
absorbed.
You will have long wavelength
transmitted.
And you will be on this end of
the spectrum,
so you would expect yellow,
orange or red,
in this case.
You can make predictions.
If you know something about the
ligand, you can predict the
color of the coordination
complex, or at least rationalize
the color of the coordination
complex.
Just to show you sort of a real
example, these are all
octahedral complexes with
cobalt.
And you can see the colors are
really dramatically different.
Depending on the ligand to the
cobalt, you can really get this
beautiful range of colors
associated.
And one of the courses that is
offered during IAP that Dr.
Shrank teaches,
you go through and actually do
some of these experiments and
see these colors.
And so it is a little lab
component that compliments
nicely this part of the course,
as well as a few other parts of
the course.
Those are these coordination
complexes.
And cobalt is also in a
vitamin.
Can someone tell me what
vitamin cobalt is in the center
of?
What is my favorite vitamin?
B12, yes.
These are colors of B12.
This is protein bound to
different forms of B12,
so there are actually different
ligands to the cobalt in these
three cases.
And these are the actual
colors.
It is really spectacular,
the colors of these.
And these are crystals of the
proteins.
The colors are really very
rich.
When you are doing experiments
on a B12 system,
you know something about the
form of B12.
If you have done some damage to
your B12, you know it by
actually looking at the color of
the molecule you are working
with.
Or the crystals or the protein
you are working with.
Very fast then,
magnetism.
Compounds that have unpaired
electrons are paramagnetic,
attracted by a magnetic field,
and ones where they are paired
are diamagnetic.
They are repelled by a magnetic
field.
You can figure out something
about the geometries often of
your compounds by figuring out
whether the compound is
paramagnetic or diamagnetic.
Well, how would you do this?
Well, if, for example,
you had a nickel two plus
system in an enzyme,
so you have a d eight
center in your enzyme,
and it is found to be
diamagnetic.
You could ask the question,
can I guess,
then, whether it has square
planar geometry,
tetrahedral geometry,
or octahedral geometry?
Because it is diamagnetic--can
I figure out the geometry
knowing that fact,
knowing about unpaired or
paired electrons?
In this case,
we would have to have,
it's diamagnetic.
All the electrons have to be
paired.
Here are our splitting diagrams
for all three cases.
Let's look at octahedral.
Again, we have to put eight
electrons in.
Here are eight electrons.
Does it matter if this was weak
field or strong field in this
case?
Which is it?
Can you tell?
Same, right,
because you would put in
electrons.
Whether you put them in one,
two, three, four,
five, six, seven,
eight, or put them in one,
two, three, four,
five, six, seven eight,
it is the same.
This could be either.
Notice we have unpaired
electrons, so this cannot be the
geometry of this unknown center.
What about square planar?
Let's put them in starting at
the bottom.
We will put them all in.
Keep going and just put them
all in.
There are eight.
It didn't really matter too
much the order I put them in
down here.
The important point is,
I really didn't want to put any
in here until I had to,
because this one,
if you recall,
is really destabilized compared
to the rest.
All right.
These are all paired up.
And let's look at tetrahedral.
Tetrahedral tends to be what
kind of spin?
High spin, because the
splitting energy is small,
because you don't have ligands
pointing directly at the
d-orbitals.
We can put them in,
in a high spin fashion,
until we are done.
And that is our system.
This is small splitting energy
down here, so we have unpaired
electrons here.
This is paramagnetic,
this is paramagnetic,
and this is diamagnetic.
Then you could predict that the
nickel and the enzyme must be
square planar.
It cannot be this and it cannot
be that, so it tells you
something about the geometry.
And I will tell you that there
are two square planar systems,
at least, in enzymes of nickel.
And people predicted it using
similar kinds of techniques to
what you just learned about in
freshman chemistry.
Okay.
Good luck on the exam on
Wednesday.